foreign
story tonight concerns home ownership so
if you are under 35 honestly this story
isn't for you it'll never be for you you
will never own a home sorry that is the
deal that you made when you decided to
be born after 1988 but we didn't want
you to feel left out so we've actually
prepared a full alternative story for
you tonight about Chuck E cheese a
different crumbling American institution
that you should go watch now instead
this is real it is 25 minutes long and
you can find it at last
squeaktonight.com please go do that now
because there is genuinely nothing for
you to see here okay
for everyone who remains this story is
about HOAs which stands for homeowners
associations not as you might have
thought horse on Adderall which I
believe is the potential sequel to
cocaine bear
HOAs also sometimes known as Community
associations our entities set up to
govern groups of hunks like a Suburban
neighborhood developments or condos and
often make local news as the villains in
stories like this it's a simple story of
a man with some simple needs sit down
and have his little
chips and a soda if he wants and say
hello to some people tan is talking
about her neighbor Ted I'll be 92 in
September and the bench outside his door
I have a place I like to come out here
and sit and relax notices from his HOA
the Bethany Villa Association saying
simply remove your bench from the common
area or it will be removed the man
deserves a place to rest and enjoy
nature and eat his little snacks and say
hello to people and pet puppies
yeah let that man of his bench
he deserves to eat snacks and pet
puppies which is by the way the single
greatest way you could spend a day
nothing tops that if on the day that
your baby was born a friend came and
told you that they spent the afternoon
eating snacks and petting puppies they
had a better day than you did the
Miracle of Life can't compete with the
simple joy of munching snacks and
scratching backs
and this is true a rub rub
also quick shout out to Tanya there the
neighbor built by that local station is
simply neighbor and Ted fan she may be a
Ted fan but I for one am a Tanya fan
because I see the effort that it takes
to put on a full face first thing in the
morning and go on the news just to say
stop with Ted but that is not a
one-off stories of HOAs being petty are
legion
a valley homeowner says her HOA wants to
find her because she installed
artificial grass a homeowners
association told one San Antonio family
their holiday decorations are up too
early so they got to come down I got
lots and lots of
um letters from the HOA telling me to
stop feeding the Ducks I mean when you
receive a violation for a tree not being
tree shaped
um it boggles your mind
yeah of course it does because what does
not tree-shaped even mean if it has
branches bark and a place for a squirrel
to store some nuts and get some
it's a tree it's tree shaped by
definition
the fact is a lot of people live in HOAs
29 of the US population lives in a
Community Association and it's actually
increasingly hard to find a home that
doesn't come with one as of all the new
single-family homes sold in 2021 82
percent were in an HOA that's up from
around just 40 in 1990 which is pretty
remarkable given that when one local
station asked viewers how they felt
about their HOA the results were nearly
universally negative with one notable
exception this was a rare comment I like
our HOA I guess I'm the lucky one but it
was quickly followed with don't count
yourself lucky too soon every HOA is
just one vote away from hellish
nightmares wow one vote away from
hellish nightmares is a pretty intense
comment it's also incidentally the dnc's
sole campaign message for the last two
elections so if they are this widely
used and this widely loathed tonight
let's look at HOAs what they are what
purpose they serve and the surprising
Powers they have to wreak havoc in
people's lives and let's start with the
basics courtesy of this old explainer
video just what is a Community
Association the association is a legal
entity created as a result of a planned
Community a board of directors is
responsible for governing your
Association working together with the
board members and committee members can
ensure that your community will run
smoothly and effectively after all board
members are owners just like yourself
okay you can really tell that video is
from the 90s not just because it's shot
with equality that can only be described
as after-school porno but also because
the board in question is just three men
and one woman that they all ignore in
other words almost every 90 sitcom the
point is hois are run by elected Boards
of your fellow homeowners and they
require the payment of dues which
average around two to three hundred
dollars a month but can be much more
depending on where you live and in
return the HOA covers upkeep of the
common areas and amenities in the
neighborhood like playgrounds or
swimming pools they also crucially
enforce architectural and Landscaping
guidelines like no benches or trees must
be tree shaped which are often trying to
push aesthetic uniformity and preserve
property values you can find HOA rules
like homes May display a maximum of two
exterior decorative objects or all
garage doors must be painted Benjamin
Moore mayonnaise OC 85. and one Arizona
HOA required that front yard landscaping
must contain a minimum of one 36 inch
box tree one 24 inch box tree 10 5
gallon shrubs and ten one gallon shrubs
and I genuinely can't tell if those are
HOA requirements for taking care of your
lawn or rules to settlers of Qatar
and those rules aren't just advisory
they are enforced through fines and hois
can be pretty unforgiving about handing
them out
take a close look at Deborah Blue's Wake
County home the color of her shutters
had her facing steep find with her
homeowners association they decided to
find me 25 a day never paid close to two
grand in fines and took down her Plum
shutters which was immediately met with
a response that now they were going to
find me in violation of taking the
shutters off the house and start finding
me again that is absurd she got fined
for the color of her shutters took them
down and then got in trouble for the
absence of shutters it's one of those
situations where no matter what you do
you lose sort of like going on The Voice
sure there are technically winners but
name a single one this show has been on
for a conservative 50 years and not a
single winner is a household name
seriously tell me the first and last
name of just one winner you can't no one
can not even Honky Tonk Frankenstein
could do it and some hlas could be
surprisingly aggressive about actively
seeking out rule violators a as this man
discovered three years after buying this
property the Henry's received a letter
from their homeowners association saying
that they were doing an audit and they
noticed that I had a shed in my backyard
and it wasn't approved by my homeowners
association Gavin who was a disabled
veteran told the HOA the shed was there
before he bought the property and none
of his neighbors have ever complained
since you can't see this from the
front yard and no one came knocking at
the Henry's front door they asked their
homeowners association how they were
able to perform an audit that's when
they were told over the phone that
Google Maps was used to scope out their
backyard yeah they spied on him with
Google Maps which feels extreme if
you're relying on the achievements of
the Space Program to find out what is in
someone's backyard it's probably not
your business
and if you're wondering how HOAs get the
authority to do all of this the answer
is they're basically born with it hois
are typically created by developers when
they build a new neighborhood they write
the HOA into deed restrictions with
membership automatic upon purchasing
your home and they're set up as
not-for-profit private corporations that
can often function like a local
government some HOAs handle Street
Paving snow plowing lighting and run
private sewer and water systems and
others even dabble in traffic
enforcement in the Parkview Community in
Spring Valley an HOA board email says
they installed this a speed camera they
say more are coming neighbor Ted Morris
says what worries him and some other
neighbors is how much a violation will
cost you for going slightly over 15
miles an hour the notice says it's 250
for the first ticket 500 for the second
one thousand dollars for the third in
any more violations for you and your
guests a thousand dollar speeding
tickets given out not by the city but by
the HOA basically the way hoa's work is
they get to set the rules and select the
punishment for breaking them think of it
like Disney World when you walk into the
Mouse's house you play by the mouse's
rules and if you step out of line goofy
is allowed to break your knees
and the existence of HOAs is something
that many local governments actually
appreciate cash strap unit
municipalities like them because
developers build roads and parks and
pass the costs along to the homeowners
in fact many municipalities even mandate
the creation of HOAs in new residential
developments which might be why the rise
of HOAs has been called The most
significant privatization of local
government responsibilities in recent
times and that gets to an important
point because HOAs can have the
authority of a government and collect
fees and fines like one but when it
comes to accountability they can
actively resist it in ways the
government officials could only dream
about after the residents have won HOA
in Arizona posted some social media
comments about an upcoming Board
election the HOA demanded that they
remove posts that were critical of its
board and threatened to find them as
much as 250 a day if they didn't and
while they eventually walked that back
that is a pretty striking level of
hostility toward basic scrutiny even
before you learn the this is how one
board member dealt with press inquiries
as the story unfolded I gotta ask you no
I'm sorry no you've got to get away from
me that's Val Vista lakes board director
Todd McCoy following a private board
meeting tonight in Gilbert after being
shocked we reiterated to McCoy that the
community was very upset to which he
replied
right now
holy he came with that reporter
with the fire of a thousand Mel Gibsons
there was almost no scenario where
yelling get away from me that
aggressively is called for aside from
maybe bumping into Ezra Miller in Hawaii
and at this point you probably won't be
surprised to learn that private
associations designed to have the force
of law in Suburban neighborhoods have a
history of being used to exclude certain
groups as we discussed in our housing
discrimination piece many neighborhoods
had racial covenants barring the sale of
housing to Black Americans and in some
cases HOAs tried to enforce those
covenants even after the Supreme Court
ruled them unconstitutional but even
today there are cases where HOAs are
used to actively exclude certain types
of residents just last June the board of
the Providence HOA in Denton County
Texas which oversees a community made up
of 2200 homes past a rule that would ban
renting a house to anyone using a
publicly financed or subsidized housing
program such as Section 8 and the
impacts of that were immediate revision
threat fears being homeless soon that's
because the rules have changed in their
Providence Village subdivision I sit in
my living room and cry because I just
don't know what to do now that is
terrible but it's not just her that new
rule threatened to displace more than
150 families renting in the neighborhood
with black families making up 93 percent
of those households and another those
HOA officials might not think of
themselves as racists but 93 percent is
a pretty solid A4 racism that hoa's
policy is now under investigation but
the fact is there is nothing in state or
federal law that explicitly forbids HOAs
from enacting bands like this it's
basically a segregation loophole which
by the way would be a pretty good slogan
for the suburbs
and if you're thinking well this all
seems up but thank God there
aren't private companies making this
worse hold on I've got some bad news
because at this point we should probably
discuss management companies you see
while as I mentioned all the big
decision making in HOAs is done by
elected Boards of homeowners they may
not have the time or skills to do
everything running in HOA entails or
they may not want to get their hands
dirty policing their neighbors that is
why the majority of HOAs hire
professional companies to handle their
day-to-day needs under the board's
Direction here is how one of the biggest
associate pitches itself the people who
serve on our boards are volunteers and
for most of them they have other
full-time jobs so our role is to come
alongside them and help do the heavy
lifting of what it takes to manage that
neighborhood that they may not have the
time for or the expertise for our role
is really to help them achieve that
Vision now in theory that sounds pretty
good doesn't it but in practice it can
get much messier than that remember Ted
who's getting his bench taken away his
neighborhood was run by associa so if
all they want to do is help a
neighborhood achieve a vision as long as
that Vision includes Ted doesn't get to
sit down I guess mission accomplished
the problem is when you introduce
for-profit companies to find problems in
your neighborhood things can change fast
many of these management companies have
people whose job it is to drive around
neighborhoods looking for infractions if
you look at that letter that Ted got
regarding his bench you'll see that it
says the infraction was noted by the
associate Arizona Inspection Team and
just watch as one woman explains just
how quickly things snowballed after a
new management company took over her HOA
first the HOA told her her trash cans
couldn't be visible from the street you
have to turn your head so far over like
this to see it for the second that you
are passing my house so she moved them
inside which is very hard to get them in
and out then the problem was her hose it
was you know all wrapped up so it really
didn't look bad then it was her lawn art
can't have those then they wanted her to
power wash her house and sweep up her
driveway but when she didn't get it done
fast enough she got late fees on top of
late fees 25 a day for each infraction
these are things that are so incidental
they're not important they're asinine
and you're charging me seventeen
thousand dollars
seventeen thousand dollars that is
clearly ridiculous I adore everything
about that woman including her
world-class delivery of asinine although
I will say I do think she could do a
little bit better with her lawn art it's
not 17 000 fine but of course not it's
just a bit of a waste when she could
have something spectacular like these
Ducks wearing boots or these ducks made
of bananas your lawn is a canvas Pat
fill it with whatever duck art speaks to
you the point is this is a system that
can quickly trap people in a vicious
cycle of debt here's how it works let's
say you fall behind on HOA payments you
might be charged interest and have to
pay additional penalties but that is
just the beginning here because once the
management company starts pursuing
payments they can involve lawyers whose
fees can be astronomical and things can
get out of hand fast here is the Bill of
just one 88 year old homeowner in Texas
she fell ill and was in a nursing home
so she missed an annual dues payment at
the start of 2021 of 423 her HOA then
started charging interest and fees for
missed payments and just five months
later her bill was already up to 682
dollars but things has really started
escalating when lawyers fees started
getting introduced because there are a
lot of them and over the course of just
two years she suddenly owed over eight
thousand dollars while over half of
which was lawyers fees and if you
wondering why lawyers are even getting
involved here it's because they often
come in when HOA is already exercise a
truly incredible power that they have
over homeowners which this woman found
out about the hard way it was a process
server who came and knocked on my door
and served me with a foreclosure notice
and of course you know I freaked out
Maisha had fallen behind on a lot of her
pills but she said she'd work something
out with the mortgage company but this
was the HOA and I had no idea that an
HOA could foreclose on you it's true
hoa's can foreclose on your home which
one of those things that sounds
ridiculous but is absolutely true like
how there are four times as many
chickens as people on earth or Lenny
Kravitz is Al roka's second cousin or
the first song Charlie puth ever
masturbated to was this love by Maroon
5. that's a true fact and I hate that I
know it but I love that you now know it
too
and this power gets deployed all over
the country Colorado's HOAs alone Falls
more than 2400 foreclosure cases from
January 2018 to February of last year
and to make matters worse those homes
can then be sold at auction sometimes
without the homeowner even realizing
just as this woman explain how despite
desperately trying to pay her late HOA
fees she wound up losing everything walk
down paid of the 2700 and when I walked
out I said this is all I owe right
yes then here comes the next set of
letters and now it's up to 6400. turns
out there were post-judgment legal fees
and 18 back interest so even after she'd
paid more than nine thousand dollars she
was still somehow behind on her dues but
in 2018 she received the most shocking
letter of all an eviction notice
you know it's you lose your home
that's hard but sadness turned to anger
when she realized the HOA had purchased
her home through foreclosure for three
dollars and 24 cents a year before she
was evicted that happened they bought
her whole house for three dollars and 24
cents and losing your home alone is
horrifying but seeing itself for so
little is genuinely insulting because
3.24 cents is significantly less than
what it costs to buy just one of those
banana ducks
they cost 17.89 and the reason I know
that is I bought one and yes I too were
surprised by how small it is
but much less surprised than I was to
learn that it technically cost more than
someone's entire house
Most states don't even require HOAs to
offer a payment plan before taking legal
action against a homeowner the reason
for that is simple remember HOAs are
private organizations that means that
the nation's 350 000 HOAs are largely
unregulated and the government sees any
disputes as private matters the
California ages office says that it does
not handle most homeowners associations
complaints the Texas Secretary of State
says that no state agency regulates home
or Property Owners associations and the
New York State AG says in most cases
there is no government agency that can
help unhappy home owners who are having
problems with their homeowners
association adding good luck which is
basically just a cute way to say you're
it's like you're washed
her hair and put on a little church
dress and if after all of this you're
thinking well I have learned my lesson I
will never buy a house in an HOA
remember over 80 percent of new homes
that are sold come with one also you
might not know that you are dealing with
a bad HOA until it is too late as in
most places you aren't legally required
to be granted access to all of its rules
until after you are offered to buy a
home is accepted which seems a bit weird
doesn't it if your HOA can see your
backyard from space you should probably
be able to see your HOA documents before
you sign and look I'm not saying that
all HOAs should immediately be gone for
a start some people do like this besides
right now local government just aren't
equipped to suddenly take over the
services like trash collection or
maintenance that they provide but at the
very least State should be looking for
ways to avoid the worst possible outcome
for homeowners who simply find
themselves in a tough spot like
mandating HOAs offer payment plans on
unpaid debt before they take legal
action and banning foreclosures based
solely on fines and attorneys fees
because at their best HOAs are annoying
student council adults telling you to
trim your shrubs and move your trash
cans but at their worst they are
glorified debt collectors with the power
to upend your life and expel people from
a neighborhood and at Absolute minimum
from now on HOA should probably be
forced to be much clearer with people
about what they are potentially getting
themselves into
good morning Stephanie and Chloe
hi there welcome to Cedar Paradise the
moment you purchased your home you
joined our wonderful homeowners
association whether you wanted to or not
the HOA is here to take care of you you
give us money and in return We maintain
all the beauty you see around us and if
you don't pay up we'll turn your
life upside down
so let me show you the neighborhood
here at Cedar Paradise each of our Lawns
requires somewhere on the property one
tree six three gallon shrubs one bird
bath a garden gnome a second gnome for
that one to talk to a third one they
ignore one Victorian child playing
hopscotch and an American flag but no
benches
please no eat Ted when you join an
HOA you're really joining a community
that looks after each other and is your
elected representative I make sure to
take a Hands-On approach
ah novelty mailbox that's a violation
oh yeah that's a violation wind chimes
gross three violations
nope I don't care for that tree
that's a violation
so staying in a 15. that's another
thousand dollars again you
and Ken isn't the only one who
appreciates everything the HOA does
the HOA that's your sons are
they found my shed by strapping a GoPro
to a raccoon
damn raccoon
some white people
apparently my cans are too visible when
they're parked up there but you'd have
to turn your neck like this to even see
them but I don't know what else I'm
supposed to do with this one hey Pam
cans aren't allowed to go down to the
curb until 4 pm on trash day it's 3 57.
how long have you been in there Pam this
is recycle only I know but damn I know
you know this Pam I know
oh no broken glass on the driveway
that's another fine are you allowed to
do that there's nothing in the rules
that says I can't these rules are stupid
I don't what did you say nothing nothing
have a good day Bob
and hey if you fall behind on your
payments we get it
we're not monsters
oh hello I'm here for the day I didn't
know I owed anything well we sent you a
20 fine three months ago we haven't
heard from you since well
here there's 20 bucks thank you but
that's not all there's this bill now too
wait what is this now I'll let our
lawyer explain and that starts my hour
where'd you come from right there no
you've got fees late fees late late fees
lawyer fees that's me fees for this
conversation we're having right now fees
there's a raccoon fee yeah the raccoon
fee anyway it comes to 11
067.38 hey wait I I can't afford that
well great news then during this
conversation we foreclosed on your house
I just bought it oh four bucks
can you break a 20. wait wait wait wait
wait this all feels really illegal oh
that's what's so great about it it's not
I'm not it's not illegal at all it's
completely legal I'm a lawyer he knows I
know you know yes wait what the yo
hey damn y'all are strong
hey you want to come to my new house
yeah please yeah let's have a drink yeah
let's see what he's got in the
refrigerator yeah good call oh there's a
lot of fun art
so welcome to the HOA I think you're
going to like it here and if you don't
tough nuts you've got no other choice
bye
foreign